this was locker-room Talk I'm not proud
of it
we've seen him great women on their
appearance
let's pretend for a moment that the
biggest headlines out of Sunday night's
presidential debate had nothing to do
with sexual assault allegations or non
handshakes or threats to jail political
opponents but instead were about policy
in that bizarre alternative universe
what we actually learn well last night
we learned the two exhausted political
parties have nothing much left except
for critiques about how lousy the other
one is some of which were to be honest
pretty good including for mr. deplorable
himself she talks in favor of the rebels
she does even know who the rebels are
look at what she did in Libya with
Gaddafi and sure enough when the most
hawkish Democrat this side of Joe
Lieberman talked about her solutions for
the war-torn Middle East it was a word
salad of safe zones and no-fly zones and
wishing really hard that good things
would happen i hope by the time i am
president that we will have pushed Isis
out of Iraq you can see the same dynamic
at play with Obamacare Trump rightly
points out the problems their method of
fixing it is to go back and ask Congress
for more money more and more money we
have right now almost 20 trillion
dollars in debt and Clinton response
with boilerplate latter let's fix what's
broken about it but let's not throw it
away and give it all back to the
insurance companies and follow so what's
president Trump solution we have to
repeal it and replace it with something
absolutely much less expensive and
something that works as for Syria it's
hard to decipher Trump's exact position
except that he definitely hasn't talked
to mike pence anytime recently
he and I haven't spoken and I disagree I
disagree disagree think you're right Mac
Isis Hillary Clinton was at her best
Sunday night when explaining why Donald
Trump was not fit to be President a
judgment with which I and about half the
Republican caucus in the Senate at this
point agree Donald Trump was at his best
when pointing out that the policy's
Clinton has supported have not been good
for the country something I wish more
Democrats would admit but is there a
positive case for Hillary being fit for
the White House are there Trump policies
that are going to turn this mother
around
no of course not
what were you thinking it's just awfully
good that someone with the temperament
of Donald Trump is not in charge of the
law in our country because you'd be in
jail secretary clip
we want to remind the audience to please
not